[Music]
I'm the one
fake California yeah it was not the kind
of food anyway so today we got a special
podcast it's episode number one 249 we
have Frank Rodriguez whom I'll play a
clip for you that if you don't recognize
he is the executive director from gays
against groomers I saw a video clip of
what he said which I'll play again in a
second uh and I said I I it's impressive
to have a message like that being given
to the audience that he did and then I
looked him up I shared it on Twitter and
then him and I got connected I want to
say Frank you and I have been talking
for
a month two months we've been going back
and forth and then eventually I talked
to Rob I said let's get you on the
calendar you're here now you're fluent
from a wonderful airport that we all
love so for those of you that don't know
gays against groomers let me kind of set
you up in a beautiful way please because
I know Wikipedia obviously whatever they
write it's got to be 100 accurate of
course it does kind of go through this
so here's Wikipedia's definition of gays
against groomers is an American
far-right
anti-lgbt organization known for
protesting against gender affirming care
for minors including including at
hospitals that provided against LGBT
representation at schools and against
drag queen Story Hour event some people
may say these are good things uh if you
call that far right you take that far
right out many parents would say these
are things I'm concerned about
a spokesperson for the LGBT advocacy
group glad has claimed that the group
uses the slore groomer to characterize
LGBT people as pedophiles gag has hosted
anti-lgbtq rallies alongside other
far-right and
anti-lgbtq organizations such as moms
for Liberty which has been attended by
proud boys and then it goes into
explaining how Jamie Mitchell started it
who before what she did and how it led
to who lives of tick tock and those
videos went viral etc etc having said
that thank you for being on a podcast
thank you for having me from your
perspective what does gays against
groomers do yeah so we're a coalition of
gay people that do not stand for the
sexualization medicalization or
indoctrination of children through the
LGBT umbrella and for instance Wikipedia
likes to you know preference that using
the word groomers and anti-lgbtq slur
and I would argue regardless of what
your sexuality is anyone can be a
groomer and so we're targeting all of
the things that are happening with
within our community that damages
children and that's going to be like
drag queen Story Hour which is
hypersexualized content in front of
children we're also pushing back against
gender ideology which is forces children
to go down a journey of chemical
castration or seeking out surgeries to
do these types of things to affirm these
genders that they feel like our
organization spends a heavy amount a
heavy excuse me a heavy amount of time
educating the public with information
sessions attending school board meetings
City Council meetings we have our voices
heard in federal legislatures and state
legislation and to be able to combat a
lot of these things our organization is
filled with so many people that have the
same vision for our community wanting to
be accountable for the things that our
community is doing and fixing it which
is why all of us identify or fall under
the LGBT umbrella so being anti
ourselves is never something that uh is
in our mission our mission is to save
children from the indoctrination that's
happening through our umbrella that's
pretty well I brought obviously we have
Jed here from the great Jedediah Billa
live show and we got a Biz Doc in the
house as well uh both of your parents
you have uh Hartley you got Bailey and
broke I got my set of kids as well this
is something that's very important to
all of us as parents it is a concern I
do want to play this clip of what got my
attention of what you were talking about
and some of you who follow the podcast
close to you saw this clip a couple
months back if you want to play this
maybe the first two minutes would be
great
every teacher that has a pride flag in
their classroom should be fired and
arrested the gay flag is a sexual flag
it represents nothing other than sexual
things gay lesbian bisexual transgender
and questioning what business is it of
anyone on this board of what children
would like to do with other children
it is none of your business it is
between them and their parents but
however you guys want to illegally
survey your students my name is Frank
Rodriguez I'm the executive director of
operations for gays against groomers I'm
a 31 year old gay man pushing back
against the agenda that's happening
within our classrooms
keeping parents away from this
discussion is absolutely severing the
relationship between a child and their
parent
my community is not discriminated
against anymore shockingly enough we
succeeded
now you're sending out surveys that's
asking students what their gender is
what their pronouns are and whether or
not you should be telling their parents
imagine
if my son or one of yours went to school
and said hey I'm gay and you never knew
all of you up here are pretty
intelligent
you have Doctorate Degrees you're
educated and you lead this District
but yet you turn a blind eye with the
sexual things that happen in your
classroom I refuse to believe that any
of you think that that's appropriate
because if you think that that is
appropriate
you would be a predator
there's images that are going to be
displayed today for you to see of a
child sucking another child off
and that's in your classrooms
I shake because it makes me
uncomfortable to even utter those words
to you
this is nothing about inclusion it is
nothing about respect to my community
I say with you with a hundred percent
truth according to the center of Disease
Control that the reason my community
faces such issues in this world has
absolutely nothing to do with the
straight people on this planet
has everything to do with the drugs that
we digest has everything to do with our
Access to Health Care the number one
reason my community has so many mental
health issues is because they don't have
access to health care and that's the
that's directly from the CDC it is not
slurs it's not gay bashing because we
don't have access to therapy
if you really want to help the lgbtq
community to feel really accepted in
this world Embrace that people have
mental health issues and they should
seek help
having a classroom without the American
flag in it is a disgrace to this country
if this country wasn't here millions of
people around the world would perish
and that flag this flag
should be held high by every single
student
so question when you gave that speech I
saw it I couldn't believe it
um you can always judge you know who is
an enemy based on who reacts to this and
who pushes back and saying I can't
believe he said this what a speech this
is ridiculous he's such a this he's such
a that who push back on your speech who
came back and said crank you don't know
what you're talking about
so the main people that push back
against this was going to be my
community the LGBT community they're
very vocal in this the the far left when
it comes to these types of things though
the woke side of this and then also a
lot of um woke women also uh pushed back
on this I think when it comes to my
community you know the gay community
when we point out these things that
really need help such as our mental
health issues or our drug addiction
rates no one wants to talk about these
things they want to brush those under
the rug but the moment you get someone
like Huntington Beach wanting to just
fly the American flag at their
facilities they get uproar they get
angry they get mad but no one fights for
the things that we actually need and so
that's why I'm really glad that this
speech that I say that shook the world
actually opened the eyes to a lot of
people because there are things that my
community needs and unfortunately
they're pushing back on it Jed your
reaction when you're hearing something
like this as a parent what are your
thoughts about this yeah as a parent and
somebody who used to work in schools
um you know this is a to me a deeply
anti-parental rights movement and the
school really wants to get in the way of
the relationship between parents and
their children and you have guidance
counselors now I'm sure you know that
are being told by Administration keep it
confidential don't make phone calls home
to parents you need to make sure these
kids are protected and they present it
as a guide of protection essentially
against their own parents so you have
kids being turned against their parents
in many respects and they feel like the
parents are the enemy they no longer
speak to their parents it breaks down
the lines of communication which
essentially enables you know
indoctrination on many levels then then
you have students in oftentimes
left-wing institutions they're not
communicating with their parents and
larger issues begin to you know be
received in terms of the indoctrination
that we see in schools I think it's
interesting though when I heard you talk
about the American flag that had to be
such an enormous trigger for these
people because a lot of the people who
are battling against what you're doing
are are also battling what this country
represents you know everything this
country represents and I think them
hearing you say that about the American
flag the response the trigger reaction
is well there's people who don't like
the American flag so you know what is
your point about those people that you
know should why can't we take the
American flag down why is the American
flag held to a different standard than
an lgbtq flag so I'm sure that they felt
incredibly triggered by that remark
because not only that do they have a
deep resentment of this country and a
deep resentment of everything it stands
for but they want to correlate what
you're uh what you're saying is true a
sexual a representation of sexuality and
a representation of just this country
the values of Liberty the values of
freedom and whatnot so I think that's I
think that's where you drove these
people to Insanity just the reference of
the American flag itself will make them
nuts so and thanks for doing what you're
doing because you know if nothing else
you're speaking out and it's I'm sure
you get I can't even imagine what comes
your way from the world community so
good for you man thank you you know I'm
I'm looking at this article what is
sexual grooming this is an article from
2017. I don't know if you have this or
not it's not a newer article uh it's uh
six years old seven things to know about
this abuse tactic okay number one anyone
can be a victim okay it often starts
with friendship got it perpetrators use
favors and Promises to build trust make
sense
five grooming can be difficult to
distinguish I'm sorry secrecy is a
common characteristic of grooming which
is number four number five is grooming
can be difficult to distinguish from
romance victims can get out family
members and friends can help but it's
important for them to tread uh carefully
so this this comment this topic of
grooming I watch Vice to the documentary
they did two weeks ago I don't know if
you saw that or not from a couple weeks
ago when it came out did you see the the
I don't think so okay it's not really a
documentary it's just a clip they put on
their Channel if you can go to it I just
send it to you on your uh yeah right
there so this whole thing that came out
to uh transphobic influencers are
driving a violent groomer conspiracy
okay so we don't need to play this clip
but if you play it you guys are in it
you know uh Matt Walsh is in it Rogan's
in it a lot of people are in it that
they're pushing back I'm sure you saw
this Jed on what they're doing okay so
the the argument of this video is there
is no such thing as groomers
okay cool no problem now play what just
came out from Project Veritas that one
you can actually play from two days ago
which I'm sure you guys have seen if
you've not seen it this is from two days
ago okay and this is what parents are
concerned about right when this uh
Reverend I think is called the Reverend
of uh what is the organization called I
think it's called the um it's out in
California
Landslide something something you know
Rabbi texted it to you if you want to
look at it uh it's an Instagram video it
says breaking groomers Reverend Casey
Martinez you know how they do what they
do if you just look at your text you'll
see that I send it to you Loomis Basin
Congregation of the United Church of
Christ Casey Martinez tinnen uh that's
the guy who was very disturbing to see
what this guy's saying in the interview
do you see it I'll just put a thumbs up
so you see it
um I think I texted you like literally 8
39 if you look up 839 send it to you
right there put a thumbs up on it
and you see have you have you taken a
look at the same every year time or no
no
I want you to listen to this if you can
zoom in a little bit so the audience can
see it there you go and refresh it so we
can watch it from the beginning
perfect
there we go audio
in my mind how communities
so I am trying to refresh and get the
audio at the same time and pause it so I
can just read the just press the button
so it doesn't play I know we're like
this close to having parents freaking
the F out is how he opens it up then
play it
to having parents freaking
in my mind
so I am the older queer folks are
mentoring Museum notes I'll be talking
about people
have you considered blockers how
critical is it
you get them when they're young
political we used to meet at the church
because it was free
you kids would say they're going to
Houston if we moved to the library
because kids said they were meeting
their friends at the library so it's not
lying but it's not fully the truth when
they know that they're queer kid is
coming to me super support they're going
to be done it's when you are purposely
misgendering them when you are purposely
not using their name how do you handle
that I call CPS but that's your standard
protocol
if we want these kids to thrive and
survive we must get to their parents
rights meet Reverend Casey tinnen of
Loomis Basin Congregational Church in
Loomis California Casey is also the
founder of the landing spot a non-profit
Community Center meant to create quote a
safe supportive and empowering space for
lgbtqia plus Youth and their families a
project
it's it's stuff like this that uh
parents see and and vice one minute is
saying no one's doing this the word
conspiracy it's a conspiracy theorist
groomers all this other stuff then you
see this and they say Okay Vice why
don't you now do something like project
Veritas is doing and really find out for
us from both sides whether this is
happening or not what's your reaction
when you see something like this uh
groomings happen in many forms it's not
just sexual grooming when you think of
grooming you're anytime you take a child
away from a parent and teach them
something that it goes against the
parents beliefs you are grooming that
child into your ideologies your beliefs
in the way that you want that child to
be regardless if that's going to be
sexual religious or any other political
ways that you think that that child
should be grooming is happening in so
many different capacities and that's why
gays against rumors is making such
Headway in this because we're breaking
barriers and destroying narratives that
the woke agenda has formed to be able to
Captivate to captive these children
against their parents like we were
saying early or if a child if like in
this video where they say that you know
children might you know commit
suicidality or something like that
having parents involved in that child's
experience from day one from when
they're born until the parents are gone
is vital to the success of that person
and that's vital for for my community if
we don't have our parents involved in
the decisions that we're making you're
setting up that child to have 40 hired
drug addiction rates 25 to be able to
commit suicide and just going down a
journey that is not supported
on their own they need their parents and
so like this video saying he can't go to
the parents that's deeply disturbing
because if a child has questions about
who they are or the journey they want to
take in their life the number one people
that can handle this conversation are
the parents I mean they can't
indoctrinate the kids though unless they
remove the parents it's integral so I
mean what that guy saying sitting and
saying a reverence no less sitting and
incur outright encouraging lying saying
you know lie to your parents he says
well it's not lying but of course it's
lying and saying that he's going to call
Child Protective Services on parents for
misgendering the kids I mean he's now
making a decision he's deciding to play
parent he's removed those parents from
the equation he said you don't matter
you're a hazard to your own children
he's made that decision and now he said
well I'm going to do a better job the
state essentially is going to do a
better job of raising your kids than you
are and it's such an integral step
because if you had parents involved you
would have pushback so what's
interesting is that for years we've had
indoctrination of kids years and years
and years and that you're right that has
been grooming and you know a lot of
conservatives have pushed back on that
for years but something different
happened here when it applied to this
stuff related to sexuality that word
groomer because that word was used
before we've been using I've been using
that word oh they're grooming kids in
schools for years but there wasn't this
type of pushback why do you think now
when it came to sexuality why why such a
pushback to the point where you've
gotten banned I'm sure we'll talk about
that where that word was banned on
Twitter where you couldn't talk about
something there is something deeply
Sinister going on with this agenda as it
relates to children and I don't know if
there's a lot of money to be made by
Pharma I don't know if a lot of
Institutions are connected but there's
something different going on that goes
above and beyond just traditional
indoctrination in schools that they are
responding to you the way that they are
what do you think that is yeah so I talk
about this a lot in my community you
kind of see it from this gentleman here
who obviously is gay a the generate or
the time that we grew up there was
definitely a time where we were
suppressed we were you know attacked for
just simply being who we were and I'm a
firm believer that a majority of my
community has not overcome that closet
trauma and now they're projecting that
onto these kids and they're suffering
the consequences of this and so you see
that in the statistics like you know 60
of my community not getting access to
mental health care and so pairing that
with what we're seeing today a lot of
the people like this gentleman here I
hate to say is probably dealing with
some sort of mental health issue that he
has not overcome and now we're
projecting this on this onto kids as if
it's going to help them and it's not
we're seeing damage we're seeing kids
you know uh seeking out gender affirming
surgeries and coming back and saying
that they don't want to transition
because of behaviors like this affirming
I I got two questions for you okay for
I'll go with this one since we are on
the topic right now uh Frank at what age
did you know you were gay
yeah so um I started thinking about you
know my sexuality probably around 10
years old and um started talking to my
parents about it and going um down that
Journey with him the most concerning
part is if I would have grown up in
today's society
um simply putting on my mom's shoes and
maybe playing around with her makeup
would have deemed me a girl and they
would have sent me to be medically
transitioned and I would no longer be
able to have kids right now so that's
why you see our community pushing back
on this because I would have fell victim
to this agenda in that video you said
your 31 year old gay man are you 31 or
32 31 31 okay so you're still 31 that's
great when's your birthday you're
January oh so we got some time to go
you're gonna celebrate 31 for a minute
so here's a question for you I asked it
before you came in and I was wondering
what these guys would say
out of a hundred gay men specifically
gay you know how many of the gay men in
America you think were born gay how many
you think were
recruited baptized indoctrinated into
believing their gay or they just had a
really rough life Father Figure was and
there was a mess parents drugs whatever
what percentage you think they were born
what percentage were like I may be I'm
not getting the attention Let Me Maybe
be gay what are your thoughts on that
yeah so I remember reading a study that
said like the more older brothers you
have the more likelihood you are to be
you know homosexual
um if I had to take a best guess I don't
have statistics on this I would say
probably 25 percent of the gay community
was you know sexually assaulted that put
them into this um Community I've seen um
you know plenty of that happen and um
probably you know the rest is is the
grooming but a majority of people I
would feel like myself just come to the
the being of you know I just I'm
attracted to the sex that I'm attracted
to
um so I would say about 25 of his best
guest 20 25 was born no 25 would have
been groomed or you know had some sort
of negative life influence that would
have led them down and you think the
other seven 25 percent is was born that
way yeah like when we say born that way
I would I would argue that it would be
growing up in a generation or in a
journey that
um you didn't have like grooming
happening where it's like you must be
gay like it's happening now you know
throwing it like I believe you mentioned
in a podcast saying it to a child a
thousand times it's gonna you know right
you know yeah yeah and so I'm thinking
you know 75 are just simply have great
parents and we're just embraced of who
they were and grew up to be a gay person
can you can you did you see the Bill
Maher episode where he talked about what
percentage of different Generations Were
Gay did you ever see that clip or no I
think it's doubled I think it went from
like one percent I gotta show this to
you so here's here's what he does and he
says if you if you look at the silence
generation 0.8 of the silent generation
born in the 40s is gay 2.6 of uh Boomers
4.2 percent of Gen X 10 and a half
percent of millennial 20.8 percent of
Jen uh what is that is that gen uh Z and
then 41.6 I don't know if 41.6 is Jen uh
Gen Y or gen C okay but but you're
seeing the trend going up obviously the
joke for him was by 2080 we're all going
to be gay that's kind of what Bill Moore
was talking about but when you when you
think about a percentage growth like
this all I think about is
is is it really 75 we we don't know I
mean no matter that's not a research
that anybody is going to really be able
to get right because if there's we all
have a friend like hey when I was a kid
I remember this one guy there were two
brothers and we knew from fourth grade
they were this you know hey I remember
when I was a kid you know this person
was I remember this girl that was we all
have a story where we look at and say
yeah that makes sense I'm not surprised
and we grew up for like 22 years old did
you know Johnny was well am I surprised
I knew at eight years old this guy was
possibly going to be this I think the
concern that a lot of parents are having
Bill Moore's not a parent this guy chose
to live a different life he's also
sitting there saying why are the
percentages of gays keep increasing the
way it does so so then the grooming
concept it gets a little bit of
credibility maybe that is happening
maybe maybe it is becoming a religion to
be part of the lgbtq community because
if that's the case and if it's a
religion what is wrong with baptizing
others what is wrong with trying to
convince you you know whether you're gay
or not whether you like men or not so
that's the argument where
you know if if other religions are
baptized and people can't I impose My
Religion on you can I impose My
Philosophy on you so do you think they
see it that way the groomers see it that
way that I'm baptizing your kids just
like the institution has been baptized
in us and to believe in we're Christians
God exists all this other stuff do you
think they see it that way
I think um when someone is grooming a
child you know to be a part of the LGBT
community I think they know exactly what
they're doing you see a lot of uh people
especially on Tick Tock you know pushing
this onto their children as if it's
something some sort of fad we use this
this phrase called trans trending and
it's because we see like in schools like
in in Castro Valley Unified School
District they paint it 10 foot uh Pride
flags on their floors in their
elementary schools if you're not putting
gay on a pedestal and popularizing it
um you know then I don't know what is so
they're putting the these this community
as a on a pedestal and everyone wants to
strive for that in school and the
students are messaging us saying that
they can't speak out they can't you know
tell people how they feel because
they're in fear of judgment they're in
fear of violence and this is happening
as young I get these messages from kids
in elementary school that they're scared
and so I would agree I would agree that
based on these numbers you can
definitely say
um you know grooming is happening at a
wide scale in our school systems and one
of the things that my site or the woke
side will will push back on is people
are more accepting now people are able
to be themselves now and come out of the
closet now and I would argue there is
absolutely no statistics to prove that
but there are statistics showing that
the more acceptance and the more we push
it in our schools the more children are
going to identify that way and if we're
want to play dumb then we cannot
acknowledge that would you would you Tom
in in uh Jed I'm going to ask you guys
as parents would you would it bother you
if they came out and they got a tax code
like Scientology and it becomes a
religion and it's no longer
um a gender you know where it's not a
gender that you're you're male female oh
my God all these other pronouns that I
gotta remember no guess what it is
moving forward lgbtq is a religion we're
non-profit organization we have
preachers we have pastors and we baptize
and yes we are converting we are doing
it the same way Christians are doing it
the same with Muslim are doing it the
same way Catholics are doing the same
way seven day you know Jehovah LDS is
doing it that's what we're doing we are
officially religion would that make you
a little bit more comfortable knowing
their motive is now clear well it would
be transparent at least yeah I mean it's
a religion already we can all
acknowledge it is a religion I mean I
always say leftism is a religion
environmentalism these radical agenda
these are religions but they they would
want never do that because part of
what's Happening Here is you know
indoctrination there's a slyness to it
there's a sneakiness to it there's a you
have to normalize The Grooming right in
order to indoctrinate you have to make
it like no this is just a new way of
life where this is we're just being
accepting and kind before we were
bigoted and we were harassing people and
now we're just making everything this is
what the new normal is and it's healthy
they need it to look like that if it
becomes a religion then they're going to
open themselves to a lot of criticism
there's going to be people that are
going to be able to say I opt not to be
a part of that and just like someone
else can say not to be a part of
Christianity or I opt not to be a part
of Judaism that would have to also be
accepted then that you make a choice and
you're either going to be part of this
whole grooming system or you're not they
don't want that they want that to be the
new normal whereby then everyone has to
adhere uh or where the Nable wear the
label of being a bigot that's the
structure that needs to be in place for
the grooming to be successful yeah you
know I look at it and their goal is is
not to be separate and contrasted they
don't want that because if you say oh
you're a religion now you're a category
now you're in a box you draw a box
around that and that's not what the
movement wants because that's going to
create contrast that's going to create
separatism oh Jewish people are like
this Muslim people like this and this
group over here is like this that's not
what they want exactly what she said
they want normalcy more importantly this
is just noise what's going on deeper
underneath is a socialist Marxist Trend
to split children away from their
parents not on any particular sexual
theme but for the state to control
thought and the state to kind of
indoctrinate kids and that's really what
the big root of the tree is and all
we're seeing on this is is kind of noise
but if they were to just you know it is
religion and she's correct it's an idea
I do understand what I'm I want you to
think about the question I'm asking yeah
just hear me out the question I'm asking
what if they flat out came and they said
they are a religion okay and you know
here's what we believe in we want to
baptize you in the name of the lesbians
the gays the you know whatever the LGBT
you know this is what we do and we think
this is a way of life
you know then you and I can sit there
because somebody somebody can argue and
say what's wrong with what we're doing
you guys are doing that okay when your
kids go to Christian Schools don't you
ask them to read the Bible and do this
isn't that a form of shaping their
mindset isn't that what you're doing
again their argument I'm just thinking
about what they're argument with the
club would be very small though because
most people don't want this what happens
is the kids go to these schools they're
groomed they're indoctrinated now those
kids are being changed and transformed
without even realizing it so they need
people to be in a system where they
don't realize what's happening to them
and it's stealthy and it's Sly and then
all of a sudden they're part of the club
and everyone has to accept it if it was
something that you that you had to join
and actually actively understand what it
was how many parents do you think would
really want their kids to be part of
that religion there would be almost no
one parents are being dragged into this
because they don't have a choice because
kids go to school all of this happens
without parental consent and before they
know it they're being puppeteered so
without the puppeteering the whole
system breaks down and that club would
actually be it would consist of you know
a lot of crazy people and some hard
leftists and it would be very small and
it would be isolated they can't have it
be isolated it needs to be media
endorsed it needs to be Hollywood
endorsed it needs to take over Society
at large or they're not happy
yeah to answer your question directly it
would at least be intellectually
straightforward and transparent and they
would say okay this is us so this is our
box this is where we are but what they
would find what you will find in there
is you would find and maybe there's a
question back for you you would find a
huge percent of people that identify as
as gay or lesbian of being equally
concerned you know about their about the
the reflection back on them so the more
separate that the the as you would say
the religion or the cult of grooming
becomes the more isolate it becomes even
from the mainstream you know gay and
lesbian
families and citizens
I I would say like the biggest
distinction when you want to like
compare it to like a religion
um you know for the aspect of grooming
you're removing those parents from to
groom that child so in this case you
would be removing the parents to groom
them in under this new religion and so
that is a big big red flag for me and I
think that it's absolutely disgusting
because when you take someone when you
take a child like your child to a church
any church of any denomination you were
grooming that child because that is your
child you make that decision as the
parent that is your child but when my
community removes you as a parent and
wants to indoctrinate that child into
this religion now you're a predator
Frank go to any one of your guys so in
the last seven eight years the seven
years the number one Pastor preacher
that baptized the most people into the
religion of Christianity 210 million
people is Billy Graham okay and the last
15 years one would say it's Joel Osteen
he does it at the old Rockets you know
Houston Rockets Arena and 80 000 people
come per weekend and he is the current
modern day who is the Billy Graham or
the Joel Osteen of the lgbtq community
baptized into most people right now
I would say RuPaul
you think RuPaul yes his show that he
puts on is hypersexualized it's put on
mainstream TV and they even spoke about
grooming in their most recent uh season
children see this on TV and granted the
things that happen on TV are not going
to be as sexual as what you see in
person but that is the gateway to want
to explore this industry now when a
child goes to a place like RuPaul's Drag
con that attracts thousands of people
you see children on stage performing for
adults in ways that are very
inappropriate and the only place that
that behavior is okay is in platforms
and places like what the LGBT community
puts up and if you take a child to a
straight bar and allow them to do these
things it's all of a sudden that's wrong
but because you paint Pride flags on the
walls and celebrate sexuality it's now
all of a sudden okay who else would you
put on that list outside of RuPaul
um would you put this Jeremy Marsh guy
up there on Tick Tock what he's doing
you know what I'm talking about yes
player yeah can you play this one here
real quick
I mean this sounds very appropriate the
way he talks just listen to this
obviously sarcastic
I it's good for children to see lgbtq
lives your parents screwed up
if you need a family
you can come hang out with me
very appropriate I mean just sounds like
a sweetheart of a guy right very creepy
yeah that's what I'm saying but all tone
but but the question I'm asking is you
know this is purely baptism this is
nothing more than Baptist this is
nothing more than you know what some of
these Cults would recruit people over
who were some of the bigger cult leaders
that we read about that you know have
done documentaries or movies about right
there's a bunch of them the model works
you know you pin them against parents
you you know create an enemy it's not
fair you make them feel welcome you make
them feel loved they go to a place
they're accepted they're a little bit
weird and hey come and be part of our
group it is a form of baptism this is
why I think it's a it's becoming a
religion this is not a gender argument
this is purely a religion and they feel
their approach right now they're about
obviously if you look at statistically
you got to give them credit they're
winning because statistically they're
baptizing a higher percentage of
generation to generation to generation
and they're winning so you guys want to
fight against that right what is your
approach to fight against that yeah so
um a lot of people don't hear from you
know our side of the gay community and
there are a lot of people on our side
that do not agree with this the moment
you such as like this gender ideology
the moment you say a man is however you
want to identify or a woman is however
you want to identify you just eliminated
gays and lesbians that's my whole
sexuality that I'm attracted to men not
someone that identifies as a man and not
someone with a prostate I'm attracted to
men and the moment you change that now
you're now I'm no longer here so that's
why a majority of our community
especially on our website that we
mentioned an overwhelming amount of the
LGBT community is not okay with what is
happening now with this gender ideology
so what we do is we go to school boards
and we we let them know like ways that
they can actually help our community in
ways that they can actually get involved
in a positive way and keep the parents
there okay let me ask you a question on
that and I'm going to ask you for an
estimate here when we look at any
political party look at the right wing
or left wing so I'm not picking any
people will say well there's the core
you know Republicans on the right and
then there's this weird Fringe and then
even core Democrats will say well you
know I'm a core Democrat I'm not out
there with um AOC I'm not out there with
Bernie I'm core right what percent would
you say when you just said my community
thinks like you and what percent is this
vocal
you know um I want to say Fringe but
this vocal group what percent would you
say that is that if you got everybody in
the room had a secret ballot how many
people that are living gay lesbian lives
families of their own would say they're
with you and what but maybe very nervous
about saying anything and what percent
is this vocal vocal group yeah so I
would argue 60 to 70 percent do not
agree with this gender ideology we get
tons of support silently from the LGBT
community and it is because of the
violence that we face every single day
um you know I've had things show up at
my door I've had people come to my door
and so that alone everything that we
have gone through everything that I have
gone through is enough to get me off of
this this journey and say you know what
I'm too scared this is this is going to
affect my life this is going to affect
my mother's life and my parents life and
it has and I tell my family all the time
this is a journey that I will I will
happily die on this hill for and lose
everything for because this is my
community I would have fell victim to
this so stick sixty percent seventy
percent of my community does not support
this and that's why gays against rumors
is so important because we're actually
providing that voice that no one has
heard before just one quick you talked
about RuPaul
um I just want to add to that first of
all and this guy Jeffrey Marsh is insane
Dylan Mulvaney
um is a very key influence particularly
with young people all over Tick Tock so
I mean there was just recently a video
that came out of him wanting acting like
a little girl I mean so and I'm curious
when we talk about this from your
perspective you talked about you know
mental illness and not having access to
the help you need how much of what's
going on now here with what you see you
know 15 genders plus you know the
pronouns everywhere what are very
clearly grown men that are acting in
very strange ways creepy videos being
targeted toward kids how much of this
that's going on now is undiagnosed
mental illness that people are afraid to
call mental illness because they're
afraid of being labeled to bigot or
whatnot and now this is being normalized
and infiltrating a movement that really
started when it came to the gay rights
movement as just Live and Let Live
you know that's a very good question
um and I'm in a very good spot to be
able to answer something like this and
before I do I just want to I want to let
her know that this comes from love for
my community it does not come from hate
I know you know leading up to the show
people wanted to say that we're just a
far right you know platform pushing
far-right ideologies but this is a
concern I would say that a majority of
it is I go down into the lion's den of
the groomer capital of the world in
California and I speak to these people
and a majority of people in my opinion
are suffering from something and just to
me I overwhelmingly just want to give
them a hug because it's like you guys
are pushing so hard for things that
don't make sense
why this doesn't this doesn't all add up
and so I would I would argue a majority
of it is and it's it's really
unfortunate because they paint us as
being these hateful people when we're
really just trying to get them the help
that they need so they can live a happy
life yeah who's the song is this on
parents is it on activists is it on
teachers is it on politicians is it on
big Pharma who who is who is this on
I wouldn't blame anyone individually I
wouldn't blame a group individually I
think it is overwhelmingly our our
country's inability to get access to
health care when you go and get get
Mental Health Services and you're able
to talk to an actual mental health
professional not someone that is a
mental health advocate for their own
personal gain but actually someone that
wants to see you get better I think that
that's where we're lacking as a country
because you see it with with the
percentages in my community
um you think six out of ten can't go see
a therapist that's deeply concerning why
can't they I would argue that we earn 10
percent less we're also 40 as addicted
to drugs so all of these things
um you know hinder us from wanting to
seek the help that we need and then also
the culture of the LGBT community if you
go down and then you interact with a lot
of our community there is not a lot of
self-accountability extreme ownership in
these things and it's very much
celebrated and accepted when you see you
your fellow gay you know digesting some
sort of narcotic to party you you you
hype them up instead of saying hey you
know what we should probably not do
these types of things and we should
probably get you some help and those
types of things you said that you make
10 less yes do you say is it is it the
lgbtq that makes 10 less or gay couples
make 10 less the LGBT okay that makes
sense because gay couples make more than
Heather heterosexual couples I don't
know if you've seen this on U.S Census
Bureau no yeah gay couples make more
money than than uh uh uh yeah if you can
pull this up it's straight up from the
Census Bureau you you may be right on
the lgbtq side but uh here if you show
there you go that's the study if you use
implements improve Arizona
zoom in a little bit 2019 uh same thing
I have couples meeting household income
a higher median household income than
opposing sex so the the reason why
specifically asked the question the way
I did uh uh yeah let's look at this here
29 same-say couples accounted for just
one percent married couple dollars the
small share is partly due to a fewer
sensex relation overall which are also
low among unmarried Partners lower
marriage race and sex couples contribute
88 offices uh amongst same-sex couples
go to the overall same-sex married
couples had a higher median income
households than opposite sex married
couples 107 to 96 respectively and
same-sex female married couples had a
lower median household income than say
some same-sex male I asked that because
uh I don't think it's I think it's right
for lgbtq I don't think it's right for
gays because they tend to typically
you'll hear if you live in a community
where there's there's a community here
what's the community here that's a gay
community Wilton Manors Wilton Manners
right Safe Community right Westwood
there's a lot of communities if the
they're there it's a safer Community but
the 40 drugs that you said why do you
think it's 40 more drug addiction what
do you think that is yeah I would say
it's self-soothing so um when you look
and see that we can't get access to that
Healthcare you see that we even consume
alcohol a little bit higher um than
straight counterparts and this comes
from the American Psychological
Association I think that we're using
that as a crutch
um and just to point out this is for
married couples right yes yeah so I was
coming from more of a single
um individual yeah um perspective not a
married perspective and so um for me
that that's what I would argue and it's
also probably the culture I would say
that you know doing these types of
things is very accepted
so you're talking about access to health
care but what I'm seeing is a lot of
people who don't want care they're not
seeking out care and saying I don't have
access they're they're getting
indoctrinated through the system where
they're now led to believe that there's
nothing wrong so they don't feel that
there's anything wrong in what they're
doing you know we watch that video of of
Jeffrey or you watch Dylan Mulvaney they
they certainly have access but they
don't want to address what's going on
there's something going on there right
if we can all acknowledge so it has to
be a combination of you know we can talk
about access but also a desire to to fix
what's going on and there's going to be
increasing number of people who don't
want to fix it because the more these
very odd Strange Behaviors and multiple
genders and drugs for kids gets
normalized the less people are going to
seek health because that's going to be
the new normal by which everybody lives
so that's going to be a deep problem you
mentioned Pharma Pat just a note Pharma
stands to make an enormous amount of
money off of all this the drugs that are
given to kids are become lifelong drugs
remember Farm Irma owns a lot of media
Pharma owns a lot of Hollywood they run
their ads everywhere so this whole thing
is connected to Big institutions that
have the power to really shape what's
going on
yeah yeah I just I just had I just had I
just searched this on the data side
before we move on uh uh I put put K
income versus
just put gay income the way I put it
like the the words I put just take that
and copy paste and put it in
because again I wanna I wanna
so a recent study has showed that in in
U.S full-time employed gay men now earn
10 percent more
then their heterosexual counterparts 20
of gay men and 25 of bisexual men
between ages of 18 or 44 live in now
below prop uh poverty levels compared to
15 levels of
heterosexual which is interesting seeing
the pay Gap that's taking place you know
I so one time very interesting what
happened to us we're in California my
wife and I we decided to get this house
and the first house we get in Northridge
in 2009 we rented we walk in and it's a
gay couple
no problem one's a lawyer one works at
Disney one works in real estate great
and we're walking through the house and
have a picture of Ronald Reagan there
and I said
I'm looking at the picture Ronald Reagan
and one of the guys looks at me says
you think it's weird don't you I I said
you know it is what it is to each his
own I said but can I ask why Ronald
Reagan he says we're conservative in
every possible way we're just gay it's
the only thing that we're different of
you know and that there's a there's a
there's a group in California what was
that group called The Gay Republican
Community there's a name that's right
Log Cabin yeah and you're seeing more
and more of that taking place these are
successful people that are doing good
for themselves they just happen to you
know like men that's taken place so from
my experience again each each one needs
to be judged in a different way lesbians
gays you know needs to be judged in a
different way in a community where
there's like gay working you know doing
what they're doing
it's typically a safer neighborhood and
it's a cleaner neighborhood from my
experience and I've seen a lot of
different places but so going back to
this because I do want to stay on this I
know it's very easy Frank you can be the
gentle one let us be a little bit mean
here you'll be nice a jet lets the rest
of us take this question because I think
we still haven't gone to the bottom of
this question
um when you run a company and the reason
why I'm wired this way I I want to have
the same mistake and not repeat again
and when you're doing anything you do
the first time you have a lot of issues
so I want to know who was that on who
was this on who was this on I don't want
to put it on anybody if we don't put it
on anybody then we don't know how to
address it right so I'm going to go back
again but I'm going to ask you from Jed
and I'm going to ask him from Tom you
can sit this one out coming if you're
ready for it if you feel like you have
some kind of Courage for this one jump
in this one jet is this on activist
is this on parents the momentum that's
being created is it on big Pharma
there's a uh what is that uh what is
that uh Lupron you know I just looked at
what the revenues was for 2022 a billion
dollars it's a nice revenue for Lupron
that's used for many different things
but you know big Pharma uh parents
politicians teachers activists
who's allowing this to happen and who's
influencing it the most so I think the
momentum the push is coming from Pharma
but the responsibility and who's
allowing this to happen ultimately rests
with parents it always rests with
parents because even you know you can
have drag shows for kids you can have
all this stuff going on yeah you don't
have to take your kids there you don't
have to succumb so it always for me
ultimately rests with parents do you
agree I think there are opportunities
opportunists up and down the street on
this I think big Pharma is being very
opportunistic I know a lot about Lupron
I'm not going to name names you're going
to detail but you know I have some
experience with this with people that
were very very close to me about the the
price for that drug and the incredible
counseling they do to talk about
potential side effects of that drug and
now it's being thrown around like
chicklets just get some Lupron it's a
puberty blocker so I think big Pharma is
absolutely opportunistic I also think
the Democrat Party is absolutely
opportunistic because there's some Court
Democrats that that are not in formed on
this they see it as a voting block and
it's part of us it's part of the Rubik's
Cube is part of the um the tetris that
makes up our voting block so I'm going
to do this and when they don't really
dive into it and understand the things
you're talking about about
um about mental health issues and drug
use that that are affecting it and so
they're opportunists and I also think
that this sits at the I think a parents
have been asleep for the past 20 years
and not really realizing what was going
on in in the schools not understanding
what was happening to take a stand about
the kinds of things that are going to be
taught to their children and now you can
take a look at you know which way the
teachers swing and donate their their
money and things politically I think
there's opportunities up and down and
each of the opportunists deserves some
of the credit or I guess you would say
blame Pat for how it's shook out but I
think the spark the spark has been the
activist once upon a time there was say
well-intended effort which ended with
the Roberts decision you can marry right
50 states you don't have to wait this
isn't the era Equal Rights Amendment
through the 70s waiting for those 37
States 35 states to ratify it right Chad
it was suddenly John Roberts that just
said never mind the states boom you can
get married and now you can get married
you have access to spousal health care I
mean a health insurance because if your
spouse Works he can say this is my
spouse and now you get access to health
insurance
um that was a big point but there's
activists that are going far beyond that
and so that's where I put it is
everybody down the street I think has a
responsibility here Pat and the
activists have been the spark the
activists can't get anywhere without
mainstream media endorsement though so
you the activists are pivotal but they
will always be viewed as sitting over
here in the corner oh they're extreme
until you get that mainstream media
endorsement so once you have the gmas
and once you have the cable news and
once you have once you have the Pharma
funded media on board and the large
umbrella saying this is healthy this is
normal this is how you take care of your
kids then those activists who would have
been relegated to the corners as
extremists are now elevated and that all
that whole umbrella becomes The New
Normal I would also add that the
increasing number of fatherless homes
particularly in this country is adding
gasoline to the fire here because if
someone is going to stand up to this
stuff it's going to be the dads in the
home the dads are going to say this
doesn't sound right to me they're less
likely to buy into woke ideology look at
how women vote look at how men vote this
is just a reality whether you like it or
not not having those dads in the home
provides there's a lot of you know
single moms out there they're leaning on
the system a lot more they're not as
financially independent they're more
Pharma dependent they're more likely to
listen to and be malleable when you have
you know schools and Nation camps coming
their way not having that stable forces
of dad in the home is leading to kids
that are coming out with a lot more
problems kids that are more easily
manipulated by social media and also a
whole structure that collapses under the
weight of a massive indoctrination
program so but this is a strange time to
be a kid it's a little scary honestly
but it is it's a strange time to be a
kid to even understand these guys but
going back to a Tom so what you're
saying is you're saying from the left
it's kind of like a voter bro voting
block like they're looking at this is a
like a a black vote they gotta win the
black vote they got to win the lgbtq
vote I just searched to see what
percentage of a vote uh voters in
America are identify as LGB it says
three and a half percent with point
three percent being transgender okay so
one side saying they're trying to win
the vote so they're going to get that
vote for the next 20 30 40 years fine
let's say that's one part of it next you
said the big Pharma is a part of it you
were going a little bit more into that
because I was watching side effects of
Lupron and I saw an article Rob I don't
know if I send you this article or not
if I did if you can pull it up it's life
sites news I don't know if you have that
one I thought I sent it to you uh life
sites news to see what Lupron does so if
you don't mind in your world what is to
the average person that doesn't know
what Lupron is what is Lupron yeah
Lupron was used to chemically castrate
uh pedophiles and now there's a small
Dosa in it in puberty blockers and so
over time this is this is the scariest
part with this narrative is people say
puberty blockers does nothing
um I would argue that if you put a child
on puberty blockers at 11 and then they
stop at 19 20. it's not just going to
resume puberty it's not a puberty
delayer you know it's a puberty blocker
so these things are are changing the
chemicals of your body and castrating
you over time yeah here's the article it
says thousands of deaths linked to drugs
used as puberty blockers for gender
confused kids if you can go a little
lower this is an article from 2019. it
got some criticism I'll give the
backside of this as well so September
20th 2019 UK National Health Services
NHS is investigating drugs that are used
to block normal sexual development among
children and teens who are transitioning
to the opposite sex that when used in
other applications have been linked to 6
000 that's the drug is questioned in
question are used to lower the levels of
testosterone and estrogen which are
built in blocks of sexual development
and sexual function the use of these
drugs in other areas of medicine to
combat prostate cancer for instance has
been associated with serial mental
conditions including cases of nervous
systems psychiatric disorders heart
failure seizures joint pain bone
deterioration and dozens of other
adverse uh events the FDA listed over 41
000 adverse reactions between 2004 and
2019 associated with luprolite which
includes Lupron and similar drugs used
by General clinics almost 26 000 of
these were classified as serious cases
which also includes six thousand that's
and I'll read this next part is FDA
indicates that amongst three to 17 year
olds who had taken the drug for various
medical conditions they were reported
almost 1500 verse reactions over 700
being serious and 11 of those resulting
in death of the cases resulting in that
the drug was used to delay puberty treat
growth disorder or drug therapy as in
hormone suppression therapy among other
things Tom
yeah so this is this this drug is a drug
that was developed to and if you look up
there's a condition that affects young
girls called precocious puberty it's
when the pituitary gland
um is out of sync with the biological
Age and what the Lupron does and it's
given in the thigh like once a quarter
with careful monitoring of hormone
levels and specifically bone density
because at puberty you notice that the
joint pain and everything people are
going to have chronic almost arthritic
joint pain because the bone development
didn't happen so not only is the bone
density but the bone size growth plates
are are completely out of sync and so
you're not just causing a sex change
what you are doing is you are chemically
changing the entire structure of that
person's body and they don't come out
the same on the other side in the case
of precocious puberty you do it once a
quarter they monitor it carefully pure
you think of like defibrillating a heart
that's beating him properly well it kind
of defibrillates the and I know doctors
probably listening to get on the chat
and say it's the wrong way to look at it
but it does it sort of resets the
pituitary gland to say hey calm down
this is what we need you to do and then
it was used in adults adult males when
you give them that it'd be it's the
chemical castration for serial
pedophiles that we don't know what to do
with them so we're gonna give them this
big time toxic drug and we're gonna
throw them in prison and so that's where
big Pharma is like anything and by the
way this was eight grand a shot that is
the market price for Lupron was eight
grand a shot so parents that had this
that was a twenty four thousand dollar a
year Neutron is eight grand a shot go
see if you can find uh I saw the
revenues a 752 million dollars in 2020
based on just this drug yeah I'm sure he
could go to like drugs.com you know the
online
um uh online legal pharmacies you know
you could go you type in Lupron price of
Lupron per shot
price of Lupron per shot you'll see
prices showing with and without uh
health insurance by the way
there you go 1729 that may be monthly
multiply that times three and there's
your there's your once again got it got
it well 1700 times three that's forty
five fifty two hundred dollars got it so
so to me when you're looking at when
you're looking at this okay so then this
leads me to the next conversation why
why such a big push for let the kids
take it if they want to before 18 years
old okay let them do it what's wrong
with that you should let them do it if
they want to do it on the parent
supports it let them go through the
process of taking this before 18 years
old why is there such a big push for
that
um I would argue that it's it's the
income you know big Pharma looks at this
as a cash cow and and if you listen to a
lot of D transitioners they are not
supported
um you know down the journey a lot of
them you know were guided especially
like someone like Chloe Cole was guided
down a journey to to go in transition
but yet didn't fully understand what she
was getting herself into didn't really
have the mental capacity at 16 15 to say
you know what I'm gonna have a double
mastectomy because I really want to be a
boy and so when you pair that with big
pharma's dirty greed you have all of
these children now that are suffering
medical consequences because they're
using data from children that are
suffering from medical illness that need
these drugs but now they're trying to
give it to healthy normal functioning
children and now we have all of these
things happening to them so when you
look at Pharma it's it's hard for people
to understand this is a new drug not
everybody's going to be familiar with
this it's the same game over and over
again so you have to look at it in terms
of something that's that's very
relatable for example birth control
pills big Pharma encourages doctors and
suppliers to consistently give out birth
control pills to young women at a very
young age you have young some young
women walking into doctor's offices for
acne for the regular cycle they're not
asked about their diet you don't look at
their stress level you don't look at any
other components that could be causing
that and they hand these birth control
pills over to young kids who then young
girls sometimes are taking these pills
from the age of 13 years old straight
through 25 years old you're now seeing a
ton of studies by the way that show that
these women have bone density issues at
a very young age they're going in for
scans at the age of 40 and they're
having bone density issues because at an
age when they were supposed to be at
their maximum capacity to build bone
they were impeded from doing that
because they were taking birth control
pills so you see the farmer recipe is oh
let's just disseminate drugs not
investigate you know what could actually
be going on lifestyle wise and otherwise
to fix this problem so now you bring in
these other drugs it's the same thing
you create a drug dependent person women
on when you talk about birth control are
very hesitant to get off because then
they're dependent they don't want to
mess up their bodies they're like oh I'm
in this routine there's a lot of panic
that goes into what are the side effects
of coming off you're going to have the
same thing with this drug whether it's
Lupron or whatever is coming down the
pike next from Pharma they want people
consistently dependent on these drugs
afraid to get off of them and it's a
permanent I think you've said it Tom
it's a cash cow it's a lifetime Cash Cow
in a lot of cases and then people who do
detransition and go off of them will
talk to you about it's not so easy to do
that as as any person who's taken any
drug any Pharma drug will tell you you
could take something as simple as a a
proton pump inhibitor for your stomach
for acid reflux there's a weaning
process that goes into that this is not
easy stuff Pharma knows it and the more
people they have Reliant and dependent
on these drugs from a young age the more
money they make it's very simple and by
the way I'll be big Pharma right well my
spreadsheet says that if you're on birth
control pills right up to the point of
uh premenopausal you know what that just
means I get you on the osteoporosis
medication earlier right and now that's
right but wait wait your joints hurt you
have issues no problem I have a cocktail
of osteoporosis medications I got stuff
for your hot flashes I've got stuff to
deal with the pain in your joints and
then and and because if you if you take
a look at it you could look at each
human being as a lifetime customer of
Pharma you can you can look at it
exactly along you know those lines you
know I I think I didn't bring up media
when I had my you know angry summary 10
minutes ago because you worked in media
and you saw pharma's influence on on
media because of the amount of spend
that they have and and we are what's the
other country besides us that's allowed
to New Zealand New Zealand's yeah
there's 22 countries out there that are
allowed to advertise like this and and
you you lived in this so I I didn't
bring up media because I I've studied
Pharma and I've studied a lot of other
things but I haven't lived in and
studied me so let's let's go let's go
with the with this uh uh next thing
about puberty blockers and what it does
so question becomes the following so
alcohol what what age is legal age to
drink alcohol
21 okay what age do I need to be to
smoke cigarettes 21 and California okay
how about if I want to uh buy a gun
I think 18 yeah 18 18 okay uh what if uh
oh what if my dad if I'm let's just say
I'm 13 years old okay and I go to a bar
and my dad says okay give him a shot of
tequila can can we do that no but my dad
said it's okay
right in 50 states your dad but wait a
minute if I go if my dad knows what's
best for me
and I go to a bar
and I say Dad I want to do a double shot
of tequila because it's been a long
freaking day in school bro it's been
tough honestly I need a double shot of
tequila right and my dad looks at the
bartender Mary it's okay give him a
double shot of tequila but he's only 13.
I'm over 21. I'm 34. it's okay go and
give it to him Mary's gonna say hey
buddy I'm not gonna lose my license do
you realize how stupid that sounds like
what I just said right now how stupid it
sounds now here's the argument Dwyane
Wade is a hero
he's a hero he wants to allow his uh
younger kid to transition and if the
father approves you should let him do
that that's a good father in today's age
in today's age the international women's
day Joe Biden recognizes a trans male
who is now a woman as the woman of the
year do you realize the level of
hypocrisy in these arguments so if a 35
year old father cannot go to a bar with
his 13 year old son and have a double
shot of tequila because he's given the
permission what makes you give that
argument to say how is this argument
creating momentum I guess is what the
question is how
yeah so a lot of the studies that that
justify you know gender affirming care
for children are done through surveying
these children that were indoctrinated
so you'll get a child you know starting
you know puberty and in two years
they'll ask that indoctrinated child if
if you feel like you're going to commit
suicide if you feel better and if you
tell that child for years and years and
years that you're a boy in a girl's body
and now they're starting to become a
girl you just manipulated that child
into being okay with what is happening
with them and so that's why this this
journey of just affirming is highly
highly dangerous because you're not
giving the child the opportunity to grow
up and make that that devastating or or
hard decision for their life at an age
where where they cannot fully understand
Frank you know what I would love you
guys to investigate because this is what
you do I'd love for you remember earlier
when I asked you a question I said out
of 100 gay men how many you think were
born that way how many of them it's
because of groomed or life or hardship
or bad father or about this about
remember how he asked yes and he said 25
percent
uh uh 25 are the ones that were affected
75 were actually gay and they've always
been gay I think that number's a lot
smaller than you think it probably is
yeah I think that number is probably
closer to five to ten percent my opinion
I could be wrong I'm just telling you my
opinion I haven't done the research on
this but if
if you guys can if somebody could go
investigate that
and figure out like even right now is
there a scientific is there a scientific
way
to figure out what it means to be gay
like meaning there is a scientific way
to say what is it to be a man right
scientific I'm born with a dangling
right yeah there is a scientific I think
that's what they call it right somebody
clip that please yeah
a girl is born with a vagina right like
that movie what was it Kindergarten Cop
hey when he tells uh Arnold schwarzeneg
he says what he says you know boys have
penises and girls have vaginas right
okay that is a scientific way and we can
even go deeper to look at the chromosome
counter say this is there a scientific
way
of defining what it is to be gay or do
we all just have to say well you said
you've been gay since you were a kid so
we have to believe it it do you know
what I'm asking Tom is there a
scientific way to say based on your
chromosome count and where you're at
you're gay
um I haven't seen anything like that
um on my end it's it's something that I
would foresee being very hard to
determine
um you know because people go through
these these life experiences and changes
you see it all the time where someone
will be like you know 55 and say you
know what I'm really gay and then they
start liking men and it's like how do
you really gauge you know how do you
quantify that experience to be able to
make a determination on it you know who
you see that a lot with too truthfully
in my experience I've seen a lot of
women who go through life they have a
family they're married they have kids
and then at 50 they're lesbian which is
and I reason that this is an interesting
point that I know you've brought up a
couple of times Pat I think is because
if you look at the stuff like with Bill
Maher that we talked about before the
numbers are exploding if you look at the
numbers of when you talk about trans how
many people you know who are
legitimately have you know body
dysphoria or have all of these issues
those are also ballooning so there has
to be a way to gauge like what is real
what is happening in someone's body
versus what is societally induced in
someone particularly with respect to you
know I'm a boy I'm a girl I'm this it's
you can't just treat people based off
nothing right they're now getting drugs
and stuff it has to be grounded in some
science here have I told you the story
about the gay bar we went to in
Nashville Tennessee I know you don't
know the story but do you know the story
okay so I'm the Army and one of our guys
his name is Chip he says
when you're ready I want to take you to
the best Underground club in all of
Nashville I'm like bro I'm ready I've
gone to all the clubs I've gone Vegas
trust me I'm ready he says no you're not
I'm telling you I've been to a lot of
crazy clubs I guarantee you've never
been to a crazy club like this I said
dude I'm I'm from L.A he says okay let's
see anyways three months later he's like
the guy that's been there longer than us
he takes me and this other guy Jeff to
this club we go to this club it's Studio
54 on steroids and by the way when I
tell you Studio 50 if you've seen the
movie where people are going at it on
the floor they're doing this over here
they're doing that they're doing this
trans drags all of it is going on at
this club okay and there's a couple
thousand people there it's Bonkers how
crazy this club was so we go in
we go in and obviously uh you know gay
men will come up to you and say hey
handsome hey
what voice because it's floating in
their own way and then there's those
that don't have the deep voice and then
you talk to you as well right like all
right cool so I'm like listen man I'm
just here for the girls and it was great
because girls would go there to not be
bothered right because they just want to
be left alone well this allowed us to go
there and if they change their minds by
11 30 there's an option
there's plenty plenty that have that
same Outlook right assure you so I'm
like you know what what a brilliant
strategy by this guy so I'm like why
does this guy always around these
beautiful girls
anyways here's what happened on the
drive home one of our guys goes to the
bathroom and this guy approaches him and
he says uh you know you guys says no I'm
straight he says before he says no he
says how do you know you're straight if
you've never been with a man before okay
and in the 45-minute drive back from
Nashville to Fort Campbell Kentucky this
guy was struggling with that question
really and I'm like I'm like bro what
are you doing
I said this is he's supposed to do that
that's kind of like how we flirt with
girls we use our like you know the line
from uh Top Gun he says you know uh you
whatever you you I don't date Pilots
well if the government can trust me why
can't she
okay cool I'm listening to the
straight guys he's like no but but what
if he's right I'm like oh you don't
understand what you're doing bro right
now you're gonna go in a very bad place
here it's going down the rabbit dude
until we're married we're all in sales
guess what Rabbit Hole he ended up going
to 2D Rabbit Hole to find out for
himself oh I'm not even kidding with you
so he goes bad it's like more than a
rabbit yeah well it is well he goes back
and he fully wants to find out
and then anyways I don't want to go into
some of the people that listen will know
who I'm talking about he ends up saying
no you know I'm not I'm straight okay
but if football went everywhere okay he
was all in like did you really have to
do this to go there he said well yes so
the reason why I asked that question is
because I think
it's uncomfortable to talk about this
today because I know what's going to
happen after this podcast today I'm
gonna get emails why are you even doing
this stick to the business stick to that
okay you're talking politics why are you
touching this you know these guys are
going to come and they're going to do
that and they're going to do this ask
him a simple question if you're saying
75 25 because of Life 75 they were born
that way I'd love to know the scientific
formula on what categorizes a person to
be
gay and then we will I mean I think it's
like dude what do you want to say that
person based on that or it's just a
choice an individual is making that
later on a lot of it could have been
persuasion by somebody else because from
my experiences I've been you know I've
been to many different places and I've
been around Straits gay Spies all of
this stuff and I understand I understand
what the approach of trying to convert
and baptize the other individual to get
them to think uh so my my question is
more I would love the research to know
exactly what that number is and I would
love for scientists who are Republican
and Democrat to work together fund the
budget to find that exactly
what needs to be the scientific formula
for us to say people are born gay I'd be
so curious to know that I think that
that's something under the Wheelhouse
that we can definitely
um you know deep dive into as an
organization we're definitely um just
you know got non-profit
um you know for the IRS so we're
definitely seeking large funding to be
able to you know pull things out and
accomplish things like this because they
think that there is a gray area that um
you know what I mean yeah that isn't
being investigated and that's something
that you know gag could definitely look
into because it goes under the grooming
wheel you know what I would want to know
I would want to know if you can pull up
if you can for a fact get to the bottom
of it and fund this with Scientists I'd
love for your organization to come back
and tell us how much that would cost
okay and you got it yeah I would love
for you to come back and say we can fund
it with this scientist that scientist
and I want it to be both sides because I
don't want to be any bias they're all
Republicans or they're all Democrats or
all this I wanted to be people at our
for the vaccination they're not for the
vaccination I don't want all of them to
be well the vax wasn't a good thing you
took or I don't want all of them to be
you should have taken a vax for Kobe
because you know vax became political
this LGBT is political everything is now
political of course if you tell me how
much it would cost to find that to get
to the bottom of it I don't know maybe
I'll either contribute or we'll go help
you raise the funds but I'm really
really curious and what I'm even more
curious about
has this study ever been done Rob can
you even pull it up like is there what
is like uh what would be the word by the
way to even search for it is a gene is
it a chromosome what would it be like I
feel like it would be something like
like in your brain activity would
probably be like where you would want to
Target
um you know certain receptors I would
assume if you were gonna gauge because
at the end of the day it's based on your
attraction right PBS so pull up that one
let's see what PBS says can you pull
that up there is no gay gene there is no
straight Gene sexuality is just complex
study confirms
can you zoom in a little bit so we
obviously know this is PBS so we know
what side they're going to be leaning to
there's no single Gene possibility you
know the first thing you need to know
about the largest genetic investigation
of sexuality ever which was published
Thursday in science the study of nearly
a half a million people closest uh the
door on the debate around the existing
of the so-called gay gene okay in it
instead the report finds that human DNA
cannot predict who is gay or
heterosexual sexuality cannot be pinned
down by biology psychology or life
experiences this study or other shows
because human sexual attraction is
decided by all these factors this is not
a first study exploring the genetics of
same-sex Behavior but the previous study
were small and under
powered the study's co-author and
genetics research fellow at the broad
Institute and Mass General Hospital on
Wednesday just to give you a sense of
the scale of our data this is
approximately 100 times bigger than any
previous study on the topic the study
shows that the genes play small and
limited role in determining sexuality
genetic heritability all of the
information stored in our genes and past
between Generations can explain eight to
twenty five percent of why people have
same-sex relation based on study results
are they going to give it to us or no
contract on a single Gene keep calling
now let's see if there's like points
what they're going to say there's a word
keep in mind of course ethical concerns
yeah I I don't know if if I know what
physically I can say somebody is
straight somebody is a man or somebody
who's a woman I'm not talking about
straight or gay I'm talking about what
is a man and what is a woman okay we can
physically look at somebody when they're
born when there's someone your baby is
born they will say you have a boy okay
and when we see the picture they'll say
this is a boy because of you know you
see the picture there's a dangling right
or this is a girl right and you go you
got a girl you got this okay great now
oh it's a boy phenomena you celebrate
but is there a way to say your kid's
going to be gay because his chromosomes
number is this and test is this this is
what's going to happen great let's
celebrate it right yeah I think um
that's going to be a really hard thing
to accomplish because I I did read a
study like through the the National
Library of Medicine that that kind of
reinforces a little bit here that there
are many influences that can help
determine or um someone's sexuality and
I think um
I think that that would probably be most
accurate that sexuality isn't just
something that is so binary that oh you
can only be straight and you will always
be straight I think we have enough you
know people in the world that have
changed that or like we spoke about but
um when it comes down to like well why
though why well why though so so so
let's go to that so a 55 year old man is
married two kids all of a sudden says
I'm gay okay we had a very like you
talked about earlier right okay we had a
very good friend drop that gorgeous girl
married to a a very famous guy in La
who's done very well billionaire money
guy all of a sudden one day she's like
nah I'm not I'm I'm I'm I'm lesbian I
like women she left her husband with two
kids and went and got what another girl
and they got married and now she's
lesbian right okay but what causes that
what causes a 55 year old who has been
married with kids like the movie whale
right you saw the movie well I don't
know if you've seen the movie well or
not with uh the guy that didn't he just
win the Oscar right Brandon Frazier that
he was a married guy with a daughter and
when she's eight or nine years old he's
a teacher he falls in love with a
student who's 23 he leaves the wife and
a daughter to go be with him and then
the guy he falls in love with ends up
having AIDS he dies and then later on he
eats so much and he kills himself right
in front the daughter this whole story I
don't know if you've seen the story no
depressing story at the highest level
don't recommend watching it Brandon
Frazier crushed the acting but the
storyline makes zero sense on how
depressing of a story this is right but
why does a 55 year old man all of a
sudden choose to be gay
I I wouldn't have the answer to that I
mean I feel like the biggest proponent
if you wanted to take a guess on that is
is social
um influence is is what is going to you
know groom someone into to behaving or
seeing something in a different light
um I would be a fool to say that you
know when you idolize something that
people don't want what you're idolizing
and so that's marketing and so it I
would I would argue that it would based
on that person's individual life
experiences that brought them to that
decision I know many of women that um
face like sexual assault and that is a
reason why that they go down the journey
it's a pretty dramatic event though it
is and so it's not genetics no but it
would it would be a proponent of that
mental state and changing your mental
Outlook because of the what happened to
you but you see I don't have a problem
with that then that to me becomes a
religion you change your religion is
what you did meaning there's a lot of
people that are atheists at 55 year old
they become Christians well why how did
you become a Christian right you read
about C.S Lewis I don't know if you know
who C.S Lewis is with the book Mere
Christianity or Chronicles of Narnia
they made a book about this guy it's a
phenomenal movie the the movie they made
about him uh divorce letters I think
he's got all these great books that he
wrote right the great divorce he's got
all these things that he wrote screw
tape letters if you've read it's a
phenomenal book screw tape letters this
guy was an atheist Oxford then he
becomes a Christian you're a pretty
smart guy what happened how do you
change yeah I joined a faith and I found
God how do some of these boxers I was
born a Christian now I'm a Muslim what
happened well a life-changing event
happened right that's a religion that's
not genetics that's not how you were
born I am born a man okay but people
influence me to say wow I like that guy
he asked the questions he converted me
right that is a religion I'm joining but
it's not how I'm born that's the
question I'm putting out there right
makes sense and would you argue then
that straight would be a religion too no
to me being born a man okay is gay
gender is gay agenda no what is gay gays
is sexuality and so straight would also
be a sexuality man and woman are genders
so male and female and implementation on
the application you know how I put you
know a male female now there's like
other this this that that's no so it's
not like male female straight gay it's
male female those are your two binary
genders yep and that's the way I see it
and then you have these people that are
going to determine their sexual
orientation and now from there you're
going to take someone that could be a
man or could be a woman and they could
be lesbian or straight or gay and so I I
could definitely you know see the lens
that you know if we wanted to claim
sexuality as some sort of religion some
sort of belief it would have to be
blanketed across everyone yeah but I'll
show you here like this these are I'm
giving you applications where they say
what is your gender and then it says
female male trans female to male male to
female intersex other
uh uh you know so and then you have the
sexual orientation which you're talking
about which is completely different like
trans okay totally get it so you're
saying uh uh gay is a religion then
straight is also religion yeah because
they're both sexual if we're gonna paint
gay as being a religion yeah then you I
feel like on the because I'm the guy
that you would have to flip at the same
way on the other coin and if gay is a
religion then so is straight because
then what you're arguing for gay you can
also argue for straight and it has to be
same on both ways for it to be factual
right I can go to a place right now that
would really get me in trouble right now
if I wanted to go there maybe we can
talk offline when I when I bring bring
up my thoughts on this year but to me an
event doesn't uh an event has to happen
for me to become gay
an event doesn't have to happen for me
to be straight
an event has to happen for me to be gay
right a crisis a life-changing event a
person I meet a conversation a grooming
groomer a person that does something for
me to question myself to say maybe I am
and I don't know and then I shift versus
I want to know naturally are there
symptoms and genetics or studies that I
can say this person's gonna have signs
of being gay that's what I want to know
because you know if it is if the
statement specifically going back to the
statement of I Was Born This Way
cool
I actually want to do studies to see
what that means
you know people say I was born this way
so so that's that's so interesting
because you know this trans movement
definitely abolishes that I Was Born
This Way mentality
um and it's that's why I argue like the
LGBT community is very full of a lot of
contradictions
um because if you're born this way if
you're born gay then why why are people
born in the wrong body you know and it's
like it's it's to me I'm very logically
consistent with it with the statements
that I make and making sure that they
are the same on both sides of that coin
and I think that that's why you're
seeing a big shift in people saying
things like LGB without the T
um gays against groomers we definitely
include the T we just don't think that
this is something for children to be
influenced by but consenting adults is
different yeah this is uh uh we went
through a whole different rabbit hole
and and trust it was interesting Frank
trust me when I tell you this off camera
at 11 30 at night having a cigar this
conversation gets a lot more comfortable
when you're talking to home team and
everybody yourself definitely then a
place like this because in a in a in a
society like today
um we have to be forced to think a
certain way that somebody wants to tell
us to believe and have a very hard time
with that I got kicked out of Bible
study from seven to ten years old
because I would say how the hell does a
if you tell me God exists and we just
got bombed 167 times explain to me how
God exists on all these people that so I
was kicked out of Bible study they
wouldn't even send me back they would
tell my mom and dad your son doesn't
need to be in class because he questions
everything in the Bible so they finally
said your son can't come to Sunday
school so I've been that guy my entire
life to question because I'm curious
if I'm born this way prove it to me I
will trust signs from both sides not
just PBS not just Fox I want a Pew
research Gallop those who supported the
vax those who didn't support the vax
those who voted for Republican those who
voted for Democrat scientists let's put
some money in there get to work and
argue and tell us you know what here's
what happens 99.8 percent of people who
become gay were converted because
somebody groomed them cool or no there's
12 that are born this way fine now we
have the signs to go based off of that
rather than all these other things that
are being forced down our throat
um I don't want to upset you it's just
oh no I'm fine I'm going through it
myself right now so be patient with my
level of curiosity oh you're totally
okay uh so so why don't we uh if we can
go to this next thing this is a
disturbing video uh before we play this
parents the reason why I'm showing this
is because
I think parents are not aware of this
enough
uh here's a guy who's a convicted uh
child predator being interviewed Tom
have you seen this before or no Jed have
you seen this before okay Frank have you
seen this no it's so disturbing it's not
even funny but it's so necessary because
the interviewer gets exactly how he
groomed young boys before molesting them
it's a two minute clip again a a brace
for impact parents I highly recommend
you watch this for your own self and
start teaching your kids before they
come across somebody like this go ahead
Rob
[Music]
grooming
um I would
check out their family situation
I would check out their clothing to see
how well they were you know financially
I would check out their
social interaction with other kids
you know when we were on the ballparks
or on on the gym floor you know I would
make sure which ones I wanted to molest
I would give them special attention
congratulate them talk to them when I
know that I would never be allowed to
talk to anybody else
you know aside from everybody I would
give them the attention that an official
is not supposed to give anybody and it
made them feel like wow he's paying the
attention
you know it is a direct form of Grooming
were there certain characteristics that
you looked for in children before
molesting them
in children yes but more I we also
looked at their families there you go if
I thought the father was a threat
I would not approach
if I thought
that the child had friends that he would
tell
I would not approach him
if I thought the child had friends that
were in the same capacity he was I would
approach him
for the simple fact that if I could
molest him
I could lure him into believing grooming
him into believing that he would enjoy
it and therefore I could manipulate him
into having his other friends
come and be molested by me as well so
perhaps a child that doesn't really have
a whole lot of friends maybe not really
a strong family
things like that yes no spiritual values
um no spiritual value week in education
you know needs help in many ways even
from split parenting you know has a
mother who may be having problems with
the family you know well here comes
superhero in to help out you know wow
well thank you very much no problem you
ever need me to take him away for the
night so you can have a night out oh my
no problem
it works
Bingo thoughts that's why I said that
about the fatherless homes it happens
all the time and it happens with
everything I mean you have to think
about like a dad in a home and what what
that means I mean even if you say you
have a daughter and she's going to date
somebody that guy is out to do no good
comes to the front door and meets pbd I
mean it's my husband good luck you know
or meets Tom good luck
um or any any Dad out there so a dad is
really like a check on on really some
bad stuff a dad has really good strong
radar a dad who is wired properly and
has his masculinity and all that intact
which is what I talk about all the time
is going to say no stop and people will
read that people out to do harm will
read that and if they see a home where
there is a mom who's home who's alone
who's struggling financially where
there's a lot of holes there that that
creates an opportunity for some really
terrible stuff to happen so that's very
interesting that we just by the way he
went he went to jail for 12 years for
molesting a number of kids in the age
you know which which really this just
shows you just how busy and how
much the citizenry isn't paying
attention not all of them and all of us
are into this I'm not putting anyone
above any others in terms of parents
everybody gets busy everybody doesn't
pay attention you have today groups that
are coming to high schools to talk about
the dangers of social media and they're
talking about Predators because
predators are bad and you've got
same-sex couples there that are just
that are coming to there concerned about
their kids being on Facebook or kids
being on social media and and and
meeting predators and going off and
having bad things happen and they're
concerned about that but then 10 minutes
later right nobody nobody you sure I'm
going Jed no it's like they have this
concern for the safety of their child
they have this concern for it but then
when they come back to what is the
school teaching what is the the average
guidance counselor doing what are people
not doing and what are they not telling
you they're not connecting the two dots
there that say listen grooming is
grooming you're concerned about
Predators over here you're concerned
about social media safety you can
concerned about really terrible things
happening on one hand but on the other
hand you've kind of not turned a blind
eye but you haven't been paying
attention to see it's it's it's come in
on the other side
you know this video points out some
really good um topics when it comes to
who has access to this information
easily who has the profession where they
can determine these types of things that
this individual did to to attack
children and I would argue that teachers
have all this information and abundance
of all of their classrooms and when you
pair something like that knowledge with
pride Flags happening and in classrooms
which I'm a huge proponent that we
should ban Pride Flags out of classrooms
you are opening up the door for these
teachers to have sexual conversations
with students that is highly
inappropriate that is not effective to
their education I argue that if if
you're hanging a pride flag in your
classroom I want you to explain that to
me as if I'm a six-year-old and it's
going to boil down to sexual preference
and that is no conversation for a
stranger and outside entity from the
family home to have that discussion with
the child and this video fully proves
that when you look at an educator as a
parent you should be questioning teacher
years more so than any person that your
child is around you should be very
involved in the things that your child
is learning because they have access to
ultra sensitive information that can
jeopardize your child's well-being
positively or negatively that's 100 true
because I used to be the dean of a
school and I would you know academic
Dean and I would work with kids age
seven seventh grade through high school
and I knew everything about their
families I knew everything about their
parents I knew what was going on in
their home I knew if that child was
troubled I know if they're on
medications ADHD medication whatever it
may be I know what their academics looks
like I know how many times they're in
and out of the office if there's an
emotional trauma or emotional problem I
know some of what's been discussed with
a guidance counselor this is 100 true
and this is why I think you've seen this
blow up in homeschooling because there's
such a deep concern about what's going
on in schools now and parents think that
they can't monitor it adequately they're
like well I'm not there all day
ultimately you are giving your children
away to an institution for a period of
time in the day you can try to to be as
present as possible you can do those
parent-teacher conferences you can have
those in person interactions but many
parents are feeling like you know
especially if they have no choice but to
put their kids in public school right
now they're feeling very very concerned
and Afraid which is why the
homeschooling industry is blowing up the
way that it is and this is for you I'm
sorry go ahead oh everything no go ahead
Tom and you know um the biz talk babe
she's a teacher and she'll tell you she
said you know that there's this odd
Chasm that gets formed parent calls you
I said the kid was in a fight she'll say
here's what we know here's what we
observed here's what the witnesses said
there's another teacher on the
playground said you get chapter and
verse you know and little kids you get
these little things called an ouch
report if they got hurt
um number one they'll tell about the
grades it's about the tests they'll tell
them if they stole from another kid
they'll tell them if they cheated on a
test you can go through the whole thing
it says has he been acting out
you can't tell then you're not supposed
to tell them the next the next parts and
she said you know this is really
troubling to a lot of teachers teachers
are not unified on this they're troubled
they're saying listen the parents should
know everything and there's a difference
between kid that's got a very bad
stepmother or an abusive relationship or
something odd is happening at home and
then there's there's some intervention
eventually is going to be needed maybe
not CPS but there's a difference between
that and then suppressing information
you can you can share everything and
anything and by the way the schools are
we got to talk to the parents because
this kid is disruptive and all the other
parents are complaining so we need to
talk to this parent so that their little
boy who's just ADHD will stop disrupting
the class and there's this urgency to do
it but the parent then wants to get a
briefing on everything you tell the
parent everything except
and it's parents now are reacting to
this saying no wait a minute this this
is kind of crazy and we shouldn't paint
all teachers like this because there's a
lot of teachers out there that are
saying no we shouldn't be putting the
limit on this but those teachers some of
them who are doesn't matter their
political affiliation their Liberals are
saying listen we got to get the parents
involved in this because but I can't say
anything and I can't say that that's my
feeling and so certain teachers are
being kind of pushed back from
expressing it by what is being
characterized as a very loud minority no
they have no power though some of those
teachers have no power because they're
working within the confines of a system
that prohibits them they can either lose
their job or they can go teach at a
private independent school which I
worked at where there's a little bit
more flexibility because you know there
aren't these you know top-down
government mandated procedures that
people have to follow but it is an
increasing problem I want to read this
story I want to read a couple of these
stories to you here's one from AP News
school library books uh book bands are
seen as targeting lgbtq content Iowa
Republican Governor Kim Reynolds pushes
an especially sweeping Crackdown on
content in Iowa school libraries the
bill she's backing could result in the
removal of books from schools libraries
in all of the state's 327 districts if
they're successfully challenged in any
one of them under a bill back by
Reynolds the titles and authors of all
books available to students in
classrooms and libraries must it would
be posted online and officials would
need to specify how parents could
request a book's removal and how
decisions to retain books could be
appealed when any District removes a
book the state's education department
would add it to a removal list and all
of iOS 326 school districts would have
to deny access to the book unless
parents gave approval to parents are the
governing Authority and how their child
is educated period said senator Amy
Sinclair parents are responsible for
their child's upbringing period Terry
Patrick a mother of two express
befunnement about why anyone would want
to make sexually explicit books
available to Children what are your
thoughts on this yeah you know I we put
in a lot of work especially here at my
home um in Orange Unified uh School
District we actually were able to flip
our board to be more conservative and
they actually terminated our
superintendent and are in the process
right now of replacing that individual
they did this because of a lot of the
sexual things that were happening to
Children within these books and so our
board actually had to make drastic
decisions and often loading an app to
get rid of these books and the question
really comes is all of these parents for
the last year or two that have been
complaining about these porn style books
that are available to students why
hasn't anyone with their right mind
saying that this should not be available
to students this should not be available
to five-year-olds and if you're going to
make it available to your your students
it should be at an appropriate age but
but here's the part I'm open to being
sold if you can logically sell it to me
how are they selling that that's normal
that you should be okay with that how
are selling it to parents yeah so
there's these things I call it gay
privilege when you paint something as
inclusivity you plain you paint it as
Pride you paint it as love as my
community you automatically get this
precedent that if you do not go along
with this then you're homophobic or
you're transphobic and no one wants to
fall under that category based on how
our society perceives these people now
you have people like us like gays
against rumors that says oh no no no no
no this book that is showing two
children have sex this has absolutely
nothing to do with pride and inclusivity
this has everything to do with
indoctrination
they associate it with book Banning now
those people you know they'll say that
people oh these are like conservatives
handbooks and that and in the meantime
if you looked back I mean would you put
Playboy magazines from back in the day
into a child School library no you
wouldn't there was some moral barometer
of what was acceptable there was a
barometer if you sent your kid into a
neighbor's house and we had a we had we
found out in our neighborhood when I was
growing up there was a guy that was a
little strange and a friend of mine
found it out because she went and baby
sat there and they were just Playboy
magazines everywhere and these were all
young and the parents said you're not
going there anymore you're not
babysitting you're not doing any of that
stuff but we had a moral barometer of
what was acceptable you have a school
library and you have kids of a certain
age bracket every book in that Library
should be pertinent for kids of that age
bracket I don't know why this has gotten
so complex and so hard and it seems to
me that what you're saying is accurate
that everyone's afraid to challenge just
this immoral stuff or this stuff that's
just not appropriate for that age group
because they're afraid of what how
they're going to be labeled then they're
going to be ostracized then you know
someone on social media is going to make
a video about them then they're going to
have a problem at their job it's going
to balloon and that person's suddenly
going to lose their job their financial
stability so everyone's like let me just
shut up and who's getting hurt are the
kids because then they go into that
school library and as a 14 year old
reading a book that's appropriate for a
grown adult and not for them so
ultimately you have to speak up people
like you who you know run these
organizations parents have to walk into
these School libraries and say I'm going
to rip my kids out of this school if you
don't stop putting inappropriate content
in this library and if a whole if a
whole school of parents showed up and
did that they'd have to change what are
all the schools going to be empty no it
doesn't work like that you band together
and you do something about it that that
kid must have lived in a high-end
Community where the parents had Playboy
magazines
we found LA Express we couldn't afford
Playboy magazine when we were 14 15
years old but I don't know if you're
little kids though she was going to
babysit five and six years but you know
even with that the responsibility of
that is still parents screwing that up
yeah which is fine let the parents screw
it up but we knew
of course now a teacher doing that and
thinking it's appropriate to put it in a
book to say you know picture two boys
what that's the part of how are you
selling these parents for some parents
to say yes Tom do you have any thoughts
on this yeah I think it goes both ways
and I think you know yeah a lot of them
do go both ways that's a different
Community that's a bisexual is that
that's next Thursday go ahead I'm sorry
I thought you were already the B that's
what the b stands for there you go we're
all learning here right you know I mean
you never know though unless if you time
tribe but go ahead you were saying I
think it's important to make to make
that point right is you know
appropriateness for all because the
you know you don't want any one
Community to say oh we're being singled
out being discriminated against well
they can claim to feel that way but
frankly for libraries we want
age-appropriate you know material all
across Spectrum you know
heterosexual homosexual all that stuff
we don't want any of that to be in front
of kids you know that's that's the point
and it's not you know Banning just gay
books or Banning just this it is
basically saying hey there's an
appropriate age for this you know you
parents for the longest time help me out
Jed because you're an administrator
could opt in or opt out of certain
videos that they would do for health for
girls sign a form in seventh grade hey
let you know next week April 11th we're
gonna do this this is the film this is
what's it about it's been used since
1985 and so parents and have a phone you
know what no I'm gonna have the
conversation with my daughter don't
she's not going to watch that film with
you
um fine and so for the longest time
there is this moral barometer and
Sensibility but it was on both ways it's
like sexualized content not going to be
in front of kids at an inappropriate age
period so nobody is singling out lgbtq
books nobody is Banning books in the
name of McCarthyism on one side of a
political line here this is kids or kids
and adults or adults and there's content
for either they sell it by the way to
parents because the same way they sold
condom distribution in schools they say
this is happening in society so we're
just showcasing what's happening in
society they also say well not every kid
has parents some kids don't have the
structure at home to explain these
things so it's our job now to stand in
and have these conversations with kids
that's outsold I just want to point out
they're going to do it anyway let's make
sure that they're doing it safely and
they use safe I just I just want to
point out these books that we're talking
about are not simply you know a dad and
a dad raising a kid taking them trigger
treating in a coloring book we're
talking about a book that is showing
kids sexual fetishes how to use sexual
objects you know having sex in these
books all cartoon is this a joke are you
being I am not joking the the speech you
saw me give in Poway Unified School
District we blew up these pictures in in
two feet by three feet and displayed
them for the school board and said these
are these are pictures you have in your
classroom books that is available to
students and when you look at these
people and they say you're homophobic
it's like this has nothing to do with
sexuality we just don't want porn in
classrooms with t with kids it's
inappropriate and they're using my this
is why when we were talking my community
the LGBT community has been hijacked
well let me go to the next story here
with what's going on in Florida Florida
said to dramatically expand its don't
say gay laws here's what they will do
this is Time magazine article obviously
uh uh oros it has nothing to do with
don't say gay laws that's just what
they're promoting Republicans lawmakers
in Florida are planning to expand
Provisions in their parental rights and
Education Act or don't say gay law which
will restrict what teachers can and
cannot say in their classrooms about
gender sex and sexual orientation the
bill would heavily restrict in-school
discussions about sexual orientation or
gender identity until ninth grade and
Bad Teacher banned teachers from
addressing students by pronouns that
differ from those they were assigned at
Birth the advocates for and against
these bills that time spoke to believe
this legislation will pass lgbtq and
Advocate plus Advocates especially fear
that the bill would have adverse effects
on lgbtq families and more than 16 000
Florida youth that identify as
transgender research by The Williams
Institute at the UCLA School of Law
found that more than half of the lgbtq
parents surveyed considered moving out
of Florida because of the don't say gay
law jet would you be heartbroken if
these parents left Florida leave see you
later bye
don't let the door hit you on the way
out no this is why it's important to
choose where you live right now this is
why it's state to state you see massive
differences by the way in terms of what
Governors are and aren't willing to
tackle I mean look at what we just saw
there they want what third graders
getting this information that is talking
about up until ninth grade they're
trying to make stuff age appropriate for
kids they're also trying to say if
you're a boy you can't just leave the
house at home a boy and everybody's you
know oh this is Jimmy and then you go to
school and somebody calls you a girl all
day long the parents don't know about it
nobody knows what's going on these are
parental rights bills these are places
that you can live by the way States like
Florida and and there are a lot of red
States some red states by the way are
slacking behind on this stuff but there
are a lot of red States you can go to
and you just know listen if something's
going on with my kid as a parent the
school is going to inform me my kid's
not going to have a whole separate life
at school than they have at home and
there's not going to be this big black
hole of nonsense going on at school
that's completely inappropriate for my
eighth grader let's say totally normal
anybody with their head on straight
would not have a problem with this stuff
Frank
um I I love the parental rights and
education bill I think it would do
tremendous positive things for my
community when it comes to addressing
kids by their pronouns you're seeing a
big push of this happen the reason this
law which I'm going to say that I
support if they do implement this is is
they are affirming these genders they
are affirming these pronouns outside of
what their parents are calling them and
so now you don't even have the parents
included in this conversation and
teachers are doing this behind their
back and so you have you know Ron
DeSantis coming in and saying you know
what no you shouldn't be doing this you
shouldn't be guiding you should not be
grooming these children you you should
be referring to them as they were born
because no child the reason gays against
groomer says no child is born in the
wrong body isn't to disavow that gender
dysphoria exists it's to put Force light
on that children do not have the mental
capacity to make these decisions fully
formed and educated decisions so that is
why no child is born in the wrong body
and you can never can well I shouldn't
say you can never but I've worn it
stands right now it's very likely that
you would not be able to convince me
otherwise because children are too
innocent and the reason why that they
are going down this journey is because
of the outside influences and we're
seeing these ramifications like with
that article with children dying I think
that article said six thousand seventy
five hundred yep and it's it's a shame
and you know who that falls on if we
want to blame someone for that that's
going to be on the teachers because the
teachers are affirming these things all
across our country without their parents
knowing and they're not even getting the
the guided assistance that they need
they're just going to school saying hey
Mr Lopez can you call me a she instead
of a he and then Mr Lopez is like sure
and it's like that is so toxic and
dangerous and confusing that you've got
the kids live in two separate lives I
mean talk about confusion and a kid in a
child's mind one thing one whole life at
home as you know Jimmy goes to school
all day gets acknowledged as whatever
now they're thinking of their parents as
the enemy they're confused they don't
know who to trust I mean that is a mess
a mess did you see the what is it Baba
Rave did you see the Cabo Baba Ray the
drag queen Ray for little children
perform for the kids you haven't seen
this do you have that Robin I've seen so
many of these things item not exactly
sure it's it's horrible I want to wrap
up with this for for if you haven't
already had enough of these videos folks
this this right here let me make it a
little bit bigger yes forgive me make
the video wider there you go so if you
if you want to if you want to play this
this is disturbing to say the least
these are kids parents took them to this
the audio is taken out on Twitter don't
worry about let it keep playing you know
it's also discussion they're sitting
there by the way he thinks that this is
okay the person doing these moves think
look at this like it's disgusting I
don't care if he thinks it's okay the
parents think this is okay let him think
this is okay I'm okay with that I don't
have a problem if he thinks it's okay
those parents who have their kids in
there tell me what the kid is learning
like what form of entertainment is this
it's not entertaining to me at all this
is like what adult adults used to go in
a bachelorette party grown adults and
see this stuff and now you have small
children well because again you have to
like you have to pause this you have to
not it's not about normalizing the
behavior like these are grown adults can
do whatever they want grown adults can
also go and spend money to go see
whatever they want right it's about
normalizing exposure of these things to
small children and it's it's deeply sick
but what is wrong with that generation
like what is the age bracket of parents
that have lost their minds here is it I
think it's like parents in there what
20s 30s and maybe even early 40s that
are doing this stuff because I can't
think of anyone above that age bracket
that I know of that thinks this is sane
but I do know some people in places like
New York City who are in their 30s or
whatever that oh yeah this is just
what's happening in the world and would
take their kids to stuff like this so I
don't know man something's deeply sick
going on Tom what what does somebody
have to pay you for you to take your
kids to that entertainment to see
something like that how much money
there there's no amount of money you can
give me same here what what is the
outcome of someone like that you know
like confusion confusion in the mind of
those kids you know
um because you see something like this
there you know it's like a sentence
there's got to be a subject a predicate
and you know a DOT at the end of the
sentence and so what are you telling the
kids when they're going in to see this
what are they seeing what are they
interpreting what do they think it's all
about and who's who's talking with them
later you know which what's really
interesting is you take third graders
second graders into a school play and
the school play is about the
Revolutionary War and then what do we do
we go back to the classroom we talk
about the play we saw and we debrief a
little bit it's called learning right
something at the front of the class then
reflective discussions and then write
something take a test all those things
you don't understand you're they're just
walking out with confusing pbd confusion
you know what I mean there's no
debriefing how many of your kids say see
something at school they see a film on
Ben Franklin they come home with a book
on Ben Franklin they debrief from Ben
Franklin and then they sit down and they
write a little piece of homework so
there's this full circle coming around
when kids go in to watch that what did
you tell them you were going to watch
what did they think when they saw it and
what did you debrief afterwards you
there's I would I want to finish with
this I want to and I appreciate that
time I want to finish with this Frank
from you from Jed from Tom so somebody's
watching this and they're saying this is
freaking ridiculous I got two kids let's
just say 40 year old and an
eight-year-old okay
I got three kids a nine a 12 and a 15
year old but I only make 73 000 a year I
can't afford to put my kids in private
school and I can't afford to stay home
because my job doesn't allow me to work
from home I have to go to my work
I don't have a lot of choices and I'm
starting my part-time real estate gig to
try to make some money so I can put my
kids in private school but I don't have
any say when I go to my school I'm in
such a liberal left community that
there's nothing I feel like there's
nothing I can do there's 20 of us
parents that we all know each other
because we go to the same church what
can I do what do you say to those
parents yet honestly what do I say yeah
both
that's what I say I know it's hard I I
know and I I understand I grew up with
very little money
um my parents didn't have a lot of money
they had to work very very very hard to
get everything that they have in life
and they made decisions based on
sometimes you just have to go if you are
in a very liberal place and the school
districts are terrible you got to figure
out a way to to get out if you can't do
the private school and you can't do the
homeschooling some families you know are
able to make sacrifices and say the dad
goes to work and there's a stay-at-home
mom and she says I'm going to take this
responsibility on not everybody can do
that some people are in situations where
they need two incomes coming in I
understand it all I also understand that
moving is not easy that there's you know
you have families where you are you have
your home you have there's a lot but but
this is not going this is not going to
get any better in these blue cities
these blue States it's moving in this
direction of these videos that we've
seen today and worse so you have to make
a decision at some point of what matters
and ultimately if you are stressed just
every single day that you send your kids
into a school and you're coming home
with a different kid you've got to
consider picking up and going to a state
where there's at least some parental
right protections where you know you
have a say in your kid's life when
they're not in your home Frank yeah I
would um argue and I would just advise
them to if you can move do so
um and then you also just have to play
an active role in what your child is
learning I I'm a huge proponent that you
should ask your children and be involved
in the things that they're learning so
you can course correct these actions and
the earlier that you can course correct
it it's very important when it comes to
you know what happens in your hometown
um gays against rumors is expanding so
quickly we get so many applications for
volunteers go to our website and see if
we have a chapter there we will deploy
someone over there to advocate for you
and shield you from these things like we
do all across our country and just
definitely just play that active role
and make sure that there are great
feedback Tom and the answer is
once you have kids you
you have to decide what you're going to
do with any spare minute of time is it
your hobbies is it your desires or are
you going to invest in this uh in this
wonderful child that you've been trusted
with and being as close to them as you
can so that you can guide with
Frameworks is point one point two is I
won't repeat it it's everything judge
has said but I think point one is just
making an avowed commitment every spare
minute I you know I don't have hobbies
it's one of the things my kids have
noticed when we were living in Dallas
they said you know Dad you don't go with
your friends to the OU football game
that's not a bad thing but I knew a lot
of guys who got these big RVs that would
go up and be gone for the weekend for
the OU football game now remember
there's only what five six home games
for OU it wasn't happening every week
but they noticed that my time was with
them not dotam what a thing you just
said so everybody hit a different point
yours was move if you can because the
fear of going to school and every day
you're like Mike is going to change when
they come up that's a real sincere fear
that people have yours is get active be
involved yours has dropped some of the
happies that are hobbies that are not
necessary you have to go to this you
have to go to that I'm going to go to
this game I'm going to drive to this and
you're missing 18 hours of being with
your kids all great feedback I will say
this to you
and this is not going to be popular
all parents love their kids I'm
convinced of course some of them that go
and they don't want the responsibility
the father lives and does parents that
are in their kids lives they love their
kids but let's face it parents
you ain't gonna like what I'm telling
you this just kind of receive it
sometimes you're a little lazy to want
to do your job as a parent it's it's an
as a leader as believe me I was a sales
leader and I didn't want to do
accountability calls how many calls did
you make this week I forget about it I
was a lazy leader in my 20s then I
realized accountability is necessary to
develop better leaders parents how was
your day today what did you talk about
what did they bring up what did you
watch who did you befriend did you have
any T did you think do this dude playing
stuff for them to kind of give you
feedback and realize you got to keep an
eye out for this you got to choose this
what about this talk to the teachers
email teachers trust me I if I were to
get a Leader's bulletin of how many
times parents email teachers to say what
happened to your the more teachers know
that the parent is involved just like
that abuser said earlier the more
involved the fathers the less I do my
thing the more involved you are the less
the teacher knows that they can't mess
with that family they got to know that
this stuff is important to you so I
think some of it is also on parents not
being lazy to be involved because your
life is so busy with a show you're
watching with a Netflix with a sports
team you're loyal to
etc etc there's nothing more valuable
for you to be loyal to than the future
of your kids that you brought onto this
world okay you're gonna need God's help
you're gonna need community help but
most importantly outside of those two
you also need to lead them properly by
being involved phenomenal podcast I
enjoyed it thank you for coming out this
was great thank you uh it's a very
different angle we took on the topic
today uh I hope you guys keep doing what
you're doing Rob if we can put that
below gaze against groomers uh what you
said was important that if you guys want
somebody to come to your community and
speak in a Lobby go to our website let
us know we will send somebody to your
area put the link in the description put
it in the chat so people can go find out
about it as well as I think you're
active on Twitter right if you can put
his handle as well on Twitter he's very
active on Twitter uh Frank thank you for
uh being courageous being brave and
doing what you're doing is not an easy
job I'm sure it's tough uh you guys get
uh targeted all the time but someone's
got to do it now you've chosen to do
this and I appreciate you for doing that
thank you thanks for coming out Jed
thank you for being on as well Biz doc
thank you as well Rob thanks for rocking
gang have a great day I think we're
doing it again on Thursday do we have
another Podcast Thursday we do we have
another one as well our live podcast
that we're doing April 6th if you didn't
purchase a ticket and you want to be at
the live podcast at the new studio with
the Cigar Lounge and everything new
announcement nobody knows
uh text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again three one zero
three four zero one one three two text
the word podcast you'll be the first to
know who will be on that podcast it's a
controversial figure but you're going to
want to hear them and you're going to
want to hear what he has to say it's
gonna be fun it's gonna be interesting
text award podcast we'll let you know
who it is on April 6 Thursday in South
Florida in the evening so it's easy to
travel and get here seven to nine pm and
it's the weekend of UFC for you to go
watch UFC Miami as well because I'll be
there myself too take care everybody
bye-bye bye